- What's up everybody?
We are back with Evangeline
Lilly and Jonathan Davis.
Give it up!
(audience applauding)
Evangeline stars in the new Marvel movie
"Ant-Man and the Wasp: Quantumania"
Meanwhile, Jonathan and
myself are big Marvel fans.
So it's time to see who knows
they're superheroes best.
This is gonna be sad for you if you lose.
- I am definitely gonna lose.
- With a superhero super quiz.
♪ Superhero Super Quiz ♪
- Oh my God.
If you lose, oh man.
- I am so gonna lose.
- You're never gonna hear the end of it
'cause we're not actually
in a Marvel movie.
- I'm only in one of them.
- Okay.
Could you give us a hand, Lord?
Do you hear us?
(ethereal chime)
- [God] Why yes, I do, Kelly.
You like? That's my
little theme song there.
That's pretty badass.
I like that.
What's up y'all?
Man, I'm so excited for
"Ant-Man and the Wasp."
I can't wait.
I'm so excited.
Wasp is my favorite.
You need your own movie, girl.
You need your own movie.
That's what I'm talking about.
Come on, now.
♪ Come on, now ♪
- [God] Yep, I went sub-atomic once.
That's how the Big Bang happened.
Anyway-
- Nice.
- [God] We're gonna play a game.
What we're gonna do today is pretty basic.
I'm gonna ask you a
question about a superhero
and the first person to hit that button
and answer will get the point.
And steals are allowed.
Now we got a Marvel prize on the line.
Even though my lawyers
won't let us say that word
too many times.
Marvel, oops, my bad.
I said it again.
Jonathan, you playing for
the people on the left
side of the audience.
(audience cheering)
- I got y'all
- Kelly, you playing for the middle?
Come on, make some noise middle.
- Woo!
(audience cheering)
- [God] And Evangeline, you
playing for the right side.
- I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry, I apologize.
- Owning it.
- [God] Good luck to y'all.
Let's get started.
Here's your first question.
What kind of doctor was Dr. Strange?
- He was a strange doctor.
- [God] He was a strange doctor.
But unfortunately, that is incorrect.
What kind of doctor?
Steals are allowed.
- We both hit it.
He gets it.
I've gotta be the host.
- I'm a guest, so I get it.
- Yeah.
- He was a surgeon.
- Yep.
(bell dings)
- [God] He was a surgeon.
Jonathan's got a point.
(audience cheering)
That's what I'm talking about.
Here we go.
- Okay.
Here's the next question.
On which eye does Nick
Fury wear an eyepatch?
Kelly.
- Right, right eye.
(buzzer buzzes)
- [God] Ooh, I'm sorry.
It's not the right
- I thought it was his right.
- That's Evangeline right there.
You could take it.
Take it, girl.
- There's only one option.
- [God] It's gonna be tough.
- The middle one.
- Yes.
- The Gods of Marvel love me.
The left eye.
(bell dinging)
- [God] It is the left eye.
- I dunno how you guessed that.
- [God] Now here's a little
bonus question for you.
How did Nick Fury lose his eye?
- Ooh, I don't remember that.
- [God] Go ahead, Jonathan.
- He lost it to an alien cat.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's right.
- [God] That is true.
It was Goose the cat.
- Oh, that's right.
- [God] Goose, the cat,
took a swipe at his eye.
Nice work, Jonathan.
Here we go.
Here's your next question
What is the superhero
name of Natasha Romanoff?
- [Jonathan] She's so fast.
- Black Widow.
- [God] It is Black Widow.
(bell dinging)
You got it.
That's Evangeline right there.
- Wait real quick.
Wasn't that in "Captain Marvel"
that we saw that happen?
Yeah, it happened in Captain Marvel.
I should get a point for
that, but whatever, it's cool.
- [God] We'll give you a point for that.
There's a point.
- It was my point though.
- Giving away, givin' away points.
- [God] It's all right, that's what I do.
I'm God, I do what I want.
- [Jonathan] God's giving away points.
- Her God.
- The tribulations, I've heard.
- All right, here's
your next question now.
This is a multiple choice.
What is Captain America's
shield made out of?
- Why did I hit my button?
I don't remember.
It's made outta like really hard (bleep)
- You need the point.
- Go ahead.
No, I don't remember.
Like, titanium, sure.
I don't know, It's some kind of-
(buzzer buzzes)
- [God] It's not titanium
- Wakanda, Wakanda!
It's the thing from from Wakanda.
- It is from Wakanda.
- What is it though?
I'll give it.
What is it?
- Vibranium, vibranium, vibranium.
- [God] It is vibranium.
(bell dinging)
- I shouldn't get that.
- You are correct.
I shouldn't get that.
because I didn't remember that.
- [God] You shouldn't.
But I'll give it to you anyway.
- We're gonna take pity on you.
- We're doing pretty well.
(air horn blowing)
- [God] Uh-oh.
That noise means it's time
for one last question.
And here it is.
- I mean...
- [God] This is for all the points.
- Better be about the Wasp.
- [God] How many infinity
stones are there.
Kelly?
- Four...
Five.
- [God] I'm sorry. It's not five.
- It was four knuckles.
(Kelly screams)
- [God] Evangeline.
(Evangeline laughs and claps)
- There are six.
- [God] There are six.
(bell dings)
That means Evangeline is the
big winner of today's game.
(kelly laughs)
- I don't know a thing about Marvel.
I just know that my son has
the glove with the knuckles.
Everyone's a winner today except for me.
That's because courtesy
of our friends at IMAX,
everyone is getting two tickets to see
"Ant-Man and the Wasp: Quantumania."
(audience cheering)
And because Evangeline won,
here photo will be hung-
(audience cheering)
on "The Chicks Wall of Champions"
I am a loser.
Whoa.
I know nothing.